CONVENE THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
ON BUDGET.
TODAY WE'RE HEARING TO BILLS SB
ONE TENNIS BE ONE ELEVEN WITH A
BOTH A SHOW SEATED WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S.
WILDFIRE PLANNED THERE ALSO
COMPANION BILLS.
TO A. B. TEN FIFTY FOUR SO.
WE HAD PARMA FINANCE HERE.
COME UP [inaudible]
WHAT THE?
YOU'RE FREE TO START AND EVERY
RIGHT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF THE
LAKE THIS ONE OFTEN FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I'M ALSO
HERE WITH A COLLEAGUE MATTHEW
HANKER WITH THE LAW FIRM
O'MELVENY MYERS.
A WHICH HAS BEEN ADVISING THE
ADMINISTRATION ON THE RESPONSE
TO A CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES.
SO THE FIRST BILL BEFORE YOU IS
SB ONE TEN THIS IS AN AMENDMENT
TO THE TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
BUDGET ACT WHICH PASSED LAST
MONTH.
AND THIS BILL BEFORE YOU DOES
TWO THINGS FIRST IT IDENTIFIES
SB ONE ELEVEN AS A TRAILER BILL --
FOR THE BUDGET ACT AND THE
SECOND THING THAT IT DOES IS IT
APPROPRIATE SAT TWO MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE -- FOR COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES RESPONSE
MEASURES.
MITCHELL REMOTE.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR SO I
HAD A QUESTION ABOUT THE WORDING
OF THE BILL BECAUSE I UNDERSTAND
THAT THE PURPOSE FOR WHICH WE
ARE PASSING OUT.
BUT THE BILL AS IT'S ACTUALLY
WRITTEN IS VERY VAGUE MERELY
SAYS THAT -- THIS APPROPRIATION
IS FOR COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF MEASURES TO
RESPOND TO THE THREAT OF
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES AND
THAT'S ALL BUT IF YOU LOOK AT AB
TEN FIFTY FOUR WHICH YOU
OBVIOUSLY IS THE COMPARE THE
COMPANION LEGISLATION. EIGHT TEN
FIFTY FOUR IS VERY SPECIFIC
ABOUT HOW THAT MONEY IS SUPPOSED
TO BE SPENT BY THE DEAL OF SO
WHY WAS IT NECESSARY TO BE SO
VAGUE AND SB ONE TIME.
SO WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION
REALIZES THERE ARE NUMBER OF
MOVING PIECES IN TEN FIFTY FOUR
AND MORE BROADLY YOU KNOW GOING
BACK TO SB NINE A ONE LAST YEAR.
SO WE WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION IS NIMBLE AND
THAT WE HAVE NO REGRETS STRATEGY
WHEN IT COMES TO THE
COORDINATION AND IMPLEMENTATION.
OF THESE MEASURES SO AS YOU
MENTIONED INTENT FIFTY FOUR
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
RESPONSIBILITIES SPECIFIC TO THE
DIRECTOR OF FINANCE THE
DEPARTMENT AND THOSE ARE
EXAMINING THE BOOKS OF THE
WILDFIRE FIND.
IT'S MAKING SURE THAT THE
WILDFIRE ALLOCATION METRICS ARE
SET IN THE APPROPRIATE WAY
THAT'S RESPONSIBILITY THE
DEPARTMENT AS WELL AS AND HE
FINDS THAT FLOW INTO THE WILD
FIRE FIND MAKING SURE THAT THE
GENERAL FUND IS A SUFFICIENT
CASH CUSHION.
BUT IN ADDITION TO THAT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT THE STATE IS
DOING FOR THE FIRST TIME IN A
REALLY SIGNIFICANT WAY IN TERMS
OF THE SCALE OF WHAT.
THE ADMINISTRATION IS TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH SO WE WANTED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE ADMINISTRATION HAD
THAT FLEXIBILITY TO SPEND IT IN
DIFFERENT WAYS AND OF COURSE.
ANY MONEY NOT SPENT WILL REVERT
TO THE GENERAL FUND AND ANY
MONEY THAT IS SPENT UPON
DIRECTION NOT THE DIRECTOR OF
FINANCE THERE WILL BE A
NOTIFICATION TO THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THE QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SAYING THAT ANY PUBLIC COMMENT
ON THE ON THE BILL.
OKAY SINGLE PUBLIC ON A WE'RE
GONNA GO TO SB.
ONE ELEVEN SO ON SB ONE ELEVEN
AS MENTIONED THIS IS A TRAILER
BILL FOR THE BUDGET -- AND AS
THE VICE CHAIR WAS MENTIONING A
LOT OF THE KEY POLICY CHANGES
ARE ACTUALLY AND AB OR SB TEN
THE ENERGY COMMITTEE.
SO WITH THE REASON THAT WE
REQUIRED THIS BILL IN ADDITION
TO THAT IS FOR TWO REASONS
NUMBER -- ONE SOME OF THE
CHANGES AS PART OF THIS OVERALL
STRATEGY REQUIRE REORGANIZATION
AND A BUDGET TRAILER BILL AS A
MORE APPROPRIATE MEASURE A
VEHICLE FOR THOSE TYPES OF
CHANGES THAT NAY POLICY URGENCY
BILL SO WE WANTED TO BUT THOSE
CHANGES.
IN THIS BILL AND THEN THE SECOND
REASON IS THAT THE RESOURCES FOR
THAT PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
THAT ARE OUTLINED IN THIS BILL --
WERE DISCUSSED AS PART OF THE
BUDGET PROCESS AND DID GO
THROUGH THE CONFERENCE COMMITTEE
I IN THE IN THE CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE MADE A DETERMINATION
TO DIFFER -- FULL ADOPTION OF
ANY SUCH MEASURES INTEL THIS
PROCESS WHEN WE HAD A TIME TO
LOOK AT THEM IN DEPTH.
SO THAT'S THE REASON IT'S IN A
TRAILER BILL AND WITH THAT I'LL
TURN IT OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE
MATTHEW WHO CAN SPEAK BRIEFLY
ABOUT EACH OF THE ITEMS IN THE
BILL.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE -- SB
ONE ELEVEN CREATES THREE
ENTITIES TO OVERSEE AND
IMPLEMENT MEASURES TO MATERIALLY
ADVANCE WILD FIRE SAFETY -- AND
TO ADMINISTER THE WILDFIRE FUND
THAT IS CREATED BY AB.
TEN FIFTY FOUR THE CREATION OF
THESE ENTITIES WILL PROVIDE
MEANINGFUL OVERSIGHT OF THE
WILDFIRE FUND ADMINISTRATOR AND
WILL RESULT IN AN ENTITY
EXCLUSIVELY FOCUSED ON THE
SAFETY OF THE ELECTRICITY SECTOR.
I ONE OF THE ENTITIES CREATE
ABOUT THIS LEGISLATION IS THE
CALIFORNIA CATASTROPHE RESPONSE
COUNCIL.
THE COUNCIL APPOINTS AN OVERSEAS
THE WILDFIRE FUND ADMINISTRATOR
AND IS COMPRISED OF NINE MEMBERS --
THE LEGISLATION ALSO REQUIRES
THAT THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION.
ESTABLISH THE WILD HER SAFETY
DIVISION WITHIN THE COMMISSION
BY JANUARY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY THE WELFARE SAFETY
DIVISION WILL RETAIN STAFF WITH
EXPERIENCE AND EXPERTISE AND
WILD FIRE SAFETY MITIGATION
CLIMATE CHANGE EMERGENCY
RESPONSE.
AND OTHER RELATED AREAS AND WILL
OVERSEE AND FORCE ELECTRICAL
CORPORATIONS COMPLIANCE WITH
WELFARE SAFETY.
FINALLY THE LEGISLATION ALSO
CREATES THE OFFICE OF ENERGY
INFRASTRUCTURE SAFETY WITHIN THE
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY.
THE OFFICE WILL BE UNDER THE
SUPERVISION OF A DIRECTOR.
AND NO LATER THAN JANUARY JULY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE ALL
FUNCTIONS OF THE WELFARE SAFETY
DIVISION ARE TO BE TRANSFERRED
TO THE OFFICE OF ENERGY
INFRASTRUCTURE SAFETY -- THANK
YOU FOR THE OPTION TO ADDRESS
YOU AND I'M HAPPY TO TAKING
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS
MISERABLE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR SO.
THE MAIN THING THAT RAISE MY
EYEBROWS WHEN I READ THIS BILL
WAS THE SOURCE OF THE
APPROPRIATED FUNDING.
SO THE FUNDING IS GOING TO COME
FROM TWO PLACES ACCORDING THE
BILL IF YOU SEE UTILITIES
REIMBURSEMENT ACCOUNT.
AND IF YOU SEE PUBLIC ADVOCATE
OFFICE ACCOUNT.
YEAH IT WAS THE LATTER THAT
REALLY CONCERNED ME BECAUSE THAT
MONEY IS SUPPOSED TO BE
DESIGNATED. FOR PREVENTING THE
I'LL USE FROM UNJUSTLY
RECOVERING FROM RATES EXPENSES
THAT THEY SHOULDN'T BE SO WHAT'S
THE ARGUMENT FOR APPROPRIATING
MONEY FROM THAT ACCOUNT BECAUSE
THE OTHER COUNT SEEMS A LOT MORE
APPROPRIATE.
SO I CAN SPEAK BEFORE THAT BUT
IT SHOULD TURN OVER TO ONE OF MY
COLLEAGUES A MAN FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WHO CAN
COME UP HERE BUT WE SAW.
THE WAY WE'RE LOOKING AT THAT
OVERALL FIFTY POINT ONE MILLION
THERE SOME MEASURES THAT WERE IN
RESPONSE TO SB NINE A ONE FROM
LAST YEAR THERE'S SOME IN
RESPONSE TO THE GOVERNOR STRIKE
FORCE.
BUT SOME SPECIFICALLY FOR THE
PROTECTION OF RATE PAYERS SO
REVIEWED THAT PREPARATION IS
SPECIFICALLY FUNDING THOSE
MEASURES BUT MY COLLEAGUES CAN
SPEAK MORE TO THAT.
YEAH HI NOW THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SO THAT TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION FOR THE REPAIR OUR
PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S OFFICE IS IN
RESPONSE -- TO A GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET B. C. P. FOR THAT PUBLIC
ADVOCATE'S OFFICE OF THAT MONEY
IS INTENDED TO GO BACK TO THE
PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S OFFICE.
IN ORDER TO CHECK -- THE
INCREASE OF WILDFIRE PROCEEDINGS
THAT WILL HAPPEN IN IT FOR THE
RATE PAYER ADVOCATE IN ORDER TO
ADDRESS THOSE PROCEEDINGS -- I'M
SORRY I DIDN'T UNDERSTAND A WORD
YOU JUST SAYS SO IT IT'S COMING
BACK TO THE PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S
OFFICE RIGHT THAT MONEY IS
INTENDED TO ADDRESS THAT PUBLIC
ADVOCATE OFFICE B. C. P. IN THE
SPRING.
HI AND SAID I WAS -- SORRY THAT
WAS PULLED BACK WITHOUT --
PREJUDICE I THINK IN ORDER TO
WAIT FOR THIS TEN FIFTY FOUR AND
SB ONE ELEVEN TO COME BACK BUT
THAT MONEY IS INTENDED FOR THE
PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S OFFICE IN
ORDER -- TO DEAL WITH THE
INCREASE IN WILDFIRE PROCEEDINGS --
THAT WILL RESULT FROM.
ALL OF THIS OKAY WELL THANKS I
WAS UNAWARE THAT I WILL TAKE
THAT OFF LINE AND MAKE SURE I
UNDERSTAND IT BUT IF THAT'S THE
CASE THEN CERTAINLY PUTS MY MIND
AT EASE YEAH.
THE QUESTIONS WERE [inaudible]
COMMENTS CONCERNS [inaudible]
OKAY -- YES PUBLICADO ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT ON SORRY ANA SB ONE
TENER SB ONE A LOT.
THAT'S IN PUBLIC OKAY.
THEN WE WILL ADJOURN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
UNDERGROUND